ترقد الام في حاله حرجه بقسم العنايه
المشدده ويتوزع اطفالها في اقسام المستشفى
حسب درجه الحروق
والحريق ناتج عن تسرب الغاز واشتعال
النيران في المنزل وهذا حال المنزل دون ان
تنفجر الاسطوانه فقط هو ضغط الغاز ادى الى
خلع النوافذ والابواب وحتى سطح المنزل
البسيط
متسببا بمعاناه كبيره لواحده من الاسر
النازحه بمارب تسرب غاز
وجئت الزوجه الصباح تشتي تولع في المطبخ
فحدث انفجار مفاجاه انفجار حتى اقترع
السطح حق البيت واشتعل البيت كلنا الاولاد
كانوا في الغرفه المجاور للمطبخ وكلهم
كلهم علقوا تتحدث تقارير صحفيه عن 12
مليون اسطوانه غاز تالفه في اليمن ضحاياها
كل يوم العشرات من النساء والاطفال اعداد
تزايدت خلال سنوات الحربيه مع توقف
الصيانه كميات كبيره من الاسطوانات غير
الامنه الى السوق المحليه زرنا منشاه
الغاز في مارب وفي منصه التعبئه يتم تحريز
اسطوانات الغاز التالفه وغير الامنه والتي
بلغت 24 الفا نعمل الجاهدين على تحريز
الاسطوانات التالفه ولدينا مخزون لا يقارب
24 الف
سوف تطلعون عليه من الاسوان التالفه لا
يمكن ان تخرج اسطوانه من المنشاه وهي
تالفه اذا في اسطوانه تالفه نحرزها في
المنصه تتحدث الجهات المعنيه عن اهمال
مشترك في التعامل مع اسطوانات الغاز ما
يؤدي لزياده حالات الانفجار وعن حلول
للصيانه بدات بالشراكه مع الجانب السعودي
وتدريب الكوادر لاصلاحها قاده الشركه عملت
في الفتره الاخيره على استخدام 100 الف
صمام يعني نوعيه جيده الان في الميناء في
عدن معانا 60 الف اسطوانه جديد في مصنع
الرياض واصلها في الطريق والاجراءات تمشيه
تباعنا ان شاء الله هو انضمين المواطنين
بان ان شاء الله وقد تحدث احداث يعني
نادره ونادر لا حكم لها الى قنابل موقوته
تتحول اسطوانات الغاز في منازل اليمنيين
ومئاسي الحرائق كثيره في كل المحافظات
محمود الحميدي العربيه مارب